I'm Amanda and I live yoga this is your
at-home yoga leg workout
hey guys today we've got a yoga leg
workout for you so we're gonna be doing
varying things poses focusing on the
legs so walk me through what we're gonna
be doing today you're gonna start right
out with the chair pose and reach your
arms up set the weight back into your
heels already activating the quads and
the hamstrings you know full forward so
you can then step your left foot back
come into a warrior 1 stance I'm just
going warrior 1 interlace the hands
behind the back roll the shoulders back
lift your chest start to lean forward so
now most of the weight is in your right
hip but keep anchoring down with that
left foot shoulders back chest lifts low
bellies pulling up and in so you're
engaging core muscles here to hold it
here can hold for you know three breaths
or so reach arms up back to warrior one
open out into that warrior - so now
you're opening up the hips stretching
the hips but also toning the under part
hamstring and quad I'm gonna bring that
right forearm down to your knee left arm
over your ear but I don't want you to do
is to lean so much into the arm that you
just push down that leg I want you to
feel white so you're already engaging
core and this is just pushing that knee
open source stretching the hip reaching
that left arm over your ear right back
up to your warrior two flip your palm
reverse your warrior
then you take the hands down and move
through a vinyasa step back to plank
lower through that chaturanga upward
facing dog downward facing dog and then
hopping back to the front of your mat
you start all over again and then move
on to the left side okay sit the weight
back into heels bend your knees reach
the arms up
alright so already I want you to think
of bringing those knees back so they
don't go over the toes put the weight
back here there you go
deep breath in exhale fold forward step
your left foot back nice bring that back
heel down reach the arms up this is your
warrior one so the hips are nice and
squared perfect interlace the hands
behind the back
keep anchoring through the outside of
your back foot lift the chest up and now
fold towards the insider to the top of
your right leg yeah torso to thigh nice
keep bending your knee over your ankle
exit lift back up into a warrior one
arms straight up to the sky there you go
keep that knee where it is now open out
to a warrior two open arms open legs
bring the right forearm down to the knee
reach your left arm over your ear there
you go now you're going to take the
right arm reach it to the front of your
mat perfect hold it here and then right
back to your warrior two yep flip your
palm reverse your warrior and then bring
the hands down to the mat as you step to
plank pose lower halfway chaturanga
elbows yep then straight back roll
through upward facing dog shoulders
rolled back chest lifts downward facing
soften knees look to the front of your
mat jumper step fold forward and then
find chair pose again and then come to
stand
hence the hurt center do we start on our
left side that's it alright that
definitely works balance as well yes for
sure just a recap we've started out with
the chair pose
coming into a warrior one stance
interlace the hands behind the back roll
the shoulders back with the chest start
to lean towards back to warrior one open
out into that warrior two right forearm
down to your knee left arm over your ear
right back up to your warrior two flip
your palm reverse your warrior take the
hands down and move through a vinyasa
and then hopping back to the front of
your mat you start all over again and
then move on to the left side so this
was definitely a very leg centric yoga
workouts very good stuff to add to your
workout routine make sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any other
fighting weight episodes